Hey guys, Pete here. we're coming up on
the end of the Game of Thrones series on
HBO and I find myself to be caught up in
all the excitement
for the past few weeks I have been immersed in the available info and
the theories
trying to figure out how this is all going to
come to an end. this video will be one
part of a preseason series which starts
out at square one.
real quick let me explain the criteria. the title says it all - 10 things that have to happen
emphasis on HAVE to happen. these aren't
things that I need or even want for that matter,
they aren't specific events that
need to happen. I am thinking about it as
fundamental things that need to happen
for a logical conclusion. as you know I'm
just a fan so these are just things that
I came up with while trying to sort out
all the different possibilities and
let's be honest there are a lot of possibilities
there's so many theories -
both good and bad theories I like that I
think might happen and theories that I
like that I don't think there's any
chance that are gonna happen. naturally
I'm gonna touch on the thinking that led
me to make this video so let's just
jump into it.
Number 1: the series needs to come to an end it needs to end. obviously that will happen,
this is the final season so I'm not talking about it in that way. the showrunners were given
the broad strokes of how the book series
will end and the show has to reflect that.
we don't need an answer for every
single question but there has to be an
actual ending, a definitive ending to the
series. I list this number one because
it's going to overlap several of the
other things and so we'll leave it at
that for now - but just a definitive
ending not something that's open-ended,
that is open for interpretation about
what happens after the series ends.
Number 2: the Iron Throne has to be
sorted out. HBO did a weird marketing
thing with season 8 where they use the
hashtag #ForTheThrone which seems kind
of out of place. the throne is important
and I'm not saying it's not, I'm just
saying that it was sort of like this
thing that "hey everybody
wants this iron throne" whenever
in the background there's a much more
serious threat that we've been waiting
to see which is what we're leading up to.
this is foreshadowed so much in
the story that a lot of people had been
led to think that the iron throne won't
even matter at the end of the day.
I tend to think that it will, but one way or the
other something has to happen so that we
know how that went down. whether John
lives and he ends up on the throne and
there's this bittersweet reason why
that's not a great thing,
whether Cersei keeps it, whether it's
destroyed, something has to happen in a
way that it is clear as to the status of
the Iron Throne at the end of the series.
Number 3: the army of the Dead has to
be stopped. I tend to think that in the
show that the army of the Dead, the
Night King, and  all the White Walkers are
going to be destroyed - but there are a
lot of other possibilities that could
make sense as well. such as a pact with
them where they go back and they leave
people alone, they leave Westeros alone.
either way they have to be stopped they
can't be a looming threat at the end of
the final episode. I'll be talking about
some of those theories and things in
other videos and in more of this video
later so we'll just leave it at that.
Number 4: it has to be bittersweet.
I'm sure you've heard this if you're a fan,
the author George RR Martin has always
said that it would be a bittersweet
ending. he told the showrunners what he
imagined to be the end and they've been
working towards that the whole time.
of course bittersweet means that there'll
be things that are good and there'll be
things that are sad, it's a pretty simple way to look at it,
but it's not going to be a Disney ending
or a completely shocking nihilistic ending.
He's been very specific about the word bittersweet.
this leaves a lot of different possibilities
based on what we know and what we think is going to happen but it's pretty essential that
we walk away thinking like wow that is actually pretty bittersweet.
Number 5: some characters have to be redeemed
we have several redemption arcs going on,
I don't know if
we'll get resolutions to all of them,
it's definitely possible. the three that
stand out are the Hound, Jaime Lannister,
and Theon Greyjoy. it's funny when you
think about it all three of these
characters have done really terrible things.
they've all been in the process
of redeeming themselves but it kind of
comes down to which character you prefer
and whether you think they're redeemable or not.
like a lot of people really love
the Jaime redemption arc and the whole
idea of him and Brienne and everything.
for me like I love Bran, he's such an
essential character for me that I never
really have been able to get on board
with Jaime's Redemption. also his
motivation seems a little bit off for
me but whatever, you know what I mean.
everybody's rooting for these three
characters or not based on what they
like and I think that at least the
majority of those have to be sorted out.
I mean obviously Theon is probably going
to do something, Jaime is definitely, we
saw him in the trailer by now he's in
the North fighting for the living, and
the Hound is probably going to do
something pretty cool as well but that
needs to you know those things are just
basic things that have to be finished up
Number 6: some of these journeys that
we've gone on have to make sense. in
particular
Bran and Arya. you know they both left
home they both spent several seasons on
these long journeys I think we get a
little bit more of an idea that Arya's
is whether I don't know it depends on
what you think but one way or another
her skills that she picked up in Braavos
seemed to be the most important thing
about her journey and then with bran
he's obviously a very powerful character
who has a very important part to play in
the ending but it's just one of those
things they sent them away for so long
that I think there's gonna be a lot of
people upset if we don't feel like those
journeys made some sense.
Number 7: and this is no surprise but some of the characters that we love will have to die.
it is Game of Thrones after all,
we're used to this. it's been a little
bit, and they've been a little bit wimpier
about it I would say in the last couple
seasons. like the field of fire 2.0 or
the loot train battle, I still
kind of when I rewatched, I don't
understand why they didn't kill somebody
off. in that Bronn was ripe for the
picking you know. nobody died
nobody important that we cared
about died and I think that in season
eight it's gonna be the opposite.
everyone that we care about that isn't
essential to the final endgame is going
to die -  but I mean we need that we need
that you know battles, situations,there has to be a cost.
I think like most people I expect that one
of the major characters if not several
of the major characters are going to die
and I think at this point it's really
just necessary that that happens for the
story to be good
Number 8: there has to be at least one surprising twist. there could be a couple.
there are definitely a lot of ideas out there s
to what these are but especially with
the way that they're building up to this
battle in the third episode, there has to
be something that we're just like "oh
yeah okay, well I didn't exactly see that
coming" in order for it to be enjoyable.
that said I don't think that this needs
to come completely out of left field and
try to shock us with some thing that we
never would have thought of but
obviously there's always been talk of
that George RR Martin gave them three
really crazy twists that they didn't
think of you know, Dan and Dave I'm
speaking of, we've seen two of those with
Hodor and Shireen - something big has to
happen. I tend to think that this has
already baked in in all the thinking
that they have, I think this is something
that they would have gotten from Martin
himself not something that they'll tack
on out of their own thinking or whatever
so let's just hope they can land the plane in that regard.
Number 9: life in the Seven Kingdoms has to go on.
I mean I guess there's an
outside chance that it won't, but I think
we all can agree that it's most likely
that there will be some version of
Westeros left over after the war for the
dawn after the White Walkers and the
night King are defeated we have to be
able to get some idea about what
happened after, since we don't have ten more seasons
to see how life carries on so
this is kind of tricky and I hope that
they're able to do that in a way that
gives us a satisfactory feeling of like
okay so all that happened you know this
is a cultural phenomenon that everyone
has been involved with for years at this
point when we think back on the world of
Westeros you know how do we see
everybody that lives there getting on
Number 10: it needs to leave us
feeling like it was all worth it.
this is a little bit vague but I think that it's
very unlikely that everyone's going to
be completely happy on the way that the
story ends there's a lot of expectation
there's a lot of people that have been
thinking about it looking over the books
you know just really invested in their
idea of how it all ends so it's not
possible that everyone's gonna be happy
that way I think what needs to be the
minimum is that when we look at it we
say okay I understand why everything
happened in the way it happened and yeah
I get it you know this makes sense that
they did it that way more than that
though I think it just has to make
literal sense and narrative sense in
that yeah this was okay I see that the
big idea it came across in Tim that's
really cool that they ended it all and
we feel good about it might not feel
like we agree with what they did or
anything else but yeah it's good it
ended way to go based off these ten
things I'm going to go into several more
videos before the season starts but
these are the things that I've been
thinking about as I mentioned this
really has been a cultural phenomenon
and I'll go into the next video that
I've been working on already about how
that is and how we might not see another
show like this at all if not soon I mean
I'm really excited about the prequel but
I don't think it will have the same
following and just excitement because it
just doesn't happen very often I mean
think about the other big shows that
have had been off lately they're all
good you know
but nobody watches them like they did
the original you know there's only
certain things kind of rise up to that
level and Game of Thrones was that and I
don't think that we'll see another show
like this based on some of the problems
that you know Netflix kind of brings in
to the game and everything else binge
watching is a lot more common a lot more
money's going towards that compared to
these shows that you know you had to
wait a whole week until you saw the next
episode you talk about it with your
friends your co-workers everything else
so when regardless of what you think
about you know anything any particular
season or the direction that's gone in
since they went off the books and
everything else it's still pretty
exciting and it's still one of the best
things that's on TV without a doubt we
can see from the trailer and from all
the information they're giving us right
now that it's gonna be exciting they put
a lot into it I hope that the pacing is
better than season seven I think that
season six in season seven actually get
a little bit better whenever you watch
them you know I just rewatched the whole
series and I think they get a little bit
better and that all that expectations of
what you wanted to happen is stripped
away but I think at the very least
there's problems with this pacing and
the the writing in season seven that I
hope that they can avoid in season eight
considering that maybe that's just what
had to happen to get us to the point
where they could tell these final six
episodes the way that they needed to be
told and I think at the end of the day
that will be all right you know I think
that we'll be able to live with that so
let me know what you guys think do you
think these are the 10 important things
that they need to do what do you think
about the individual things how do you
want to see it end where is your
investment and what are you thinking
what can't you live with what can you
live with how worried are you that it's
not going to end well leave a comment
tell me what you think please like the
video if you enjoyed it I'll be doing
plenty of new stuff before the season
comes out so join along with me I
appreciate your watching thanks a lot
I'll talk to you soon